What are your thoughts about black sand?
So I assume you're asking about black sand the black sand the sand itself
So black sand is used its blood root
Sam that is used topically to treat
melodomas and
Squamous cell cancers and it is
Can be fantastic, but you have to do your research. It's not something you just jumped into and put black sand on
It opened breast wound or black sand on a melodoma
Without looking at a bunch of videos. There's a ton of videos online
YouTube different YouTube channels. I would say look at the two feathers product. Yeah, that's one product
You could take it internally. Yes, it's but I would use the black sand blood root capsules
If you're going to take it internally because
There it has granule and some other things in it, too
But
Anyway, yeah, yes, they could you could use it topically you could use it internally
But you just have to be careful with it do your research on it before you
Before you you take it make sure you know, especially if you're going to do the topical make sure that you
have
Have looked at the videos and the websites out there blacksam info.com is a good website where you could gather about your information
About black sand topical use as well